Speaker 1: One of the incredible things that
has happened in the context of the Russian
invasion of Ukraine is that much of the world
has become united against Russia and in defense
of Ukraine.
You look at the list of countries now sending
military support, weapons support rather to
Ukraine.
It's an incredible list and with some rare
exceptions, I mean, you know, Belarus and
you know, the typical handful of exceptions.
Much of the world has not been as united for
or against anything as we have seen over the
last week.
And as I've said before, the Ukrainian President
Zelensky was not particularly popular before
this started, and there are still all sorts
of concerns when it comes to corruption in
Ukraine, as we've talked about before.
But the degree to which he has become.
Quite often, I say as a joke.
Defiant and principled, but he has remained
defiant and principled in a way that people
the world over are really rallying behind.
And most recently with a quite frankly, of
irate viral speech to European Parliament,
during which you'll hear the translator become
audibly emotional, leading to a minute long
standing ovation after the second clip.
Let's take a listen, and this is the voice
of the translator that you will hear.
Speaker 2: We are fighting just for our land
and for our freedom.
Despite the fact that all large cities of
our country are now blocked, nobody is going
to enter and intervene with our freedom and
country.
And believe you me.
Every square today, no matter what it's called,
it's going to be called as today, Freedom
Square in every city of our country.
Nobody is going to break us.
We are strong.
We are Ukrainians.
Speaker 1: And of course, the hope would be
that indeed, Ukraine will be able to repel
the invasion from Russia.
We don't know that know that yet.
And if it doesn't happen, it will not be from
lack of desire or resolve.
It will be because of the sheer size of the
Russian military.
And the most recent reports are that Kharkiv
is increasingly surrounded.
And you know, it's so hard to know what is
really going on because many of the reports
that have come out later are retracted or
were based on confused or incorrect information.
But the desire is there, and here is more
from the Ukrainian President Selenski ending
his speech before European Parliament to a
minute long standing ovation.
Speaker 2: So do prove that you are with us.
Do prove that you will not let us go.
Do prove that you indeed are Europeans and
then life will win over death and light will
win over darkness.
Glory be to Ukraine.
Speaker 1: So as you can tell, quite a united
planet at this point in time, and there are,
as always, conflicting reports coming out
of Russia, on the one hand, when it comes
to the military front, like I just said reports
that Kharkiv is in an increasingly precarious
situation as of the last three or four hours
surrounded and that things are not looking
good.
At the same time, there are multiple reports
that Putin's grip, so to speak on power, may
be starting to slip, at least ideologically.
Yahoo News Daily Beast article Rather, the
Russian people may be starting to think Putin
is insane, and I encourage you.
I mean, listen, I encourage people to read
all of the things that are being written and
understand that what really happened if we
will ever fully know the story, it's only
going to be in retrospect.
But we will, of course, continue covering
what is going on and hope, hope that indeed,
Ukrainian forces and allies are going to be
able to repeal repel this horrifying invasion.
And we will continue talking about what the
what the next steps may be.
And quite frankly, Joe Biden's State of the
Union address tonight, which we'll be covering
live, may give us some of that information.
In the meantime, there's much more to talk
about here, and I want to talk next about
an incredible statement made by the Ukrainian
ambassador to the United Nations.